[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hi, welcome
to Google Developers Live.
This is mobile web Thursday.
But actually, we're not live.
We're pre-recording this.
And I guess it's not really
Google Developers, either,
because you're not
one of the gang.
So I guess it's just developers
not live in a
Google studio.
So it's not GDL it's DNLIAGS,
din-a-lags, DNLIAGS.
That's cool.
It kind of sounds a bit
like dinner ladies.
We could go with that.
REMY SHARP: Din ladies.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Anyway the studio today, we've
got Remy Sharp from off of the
internet, from down
in Brighton.
And I certainly hope he's going
to brighten the studio.
REMY SHARP: [DRUM ROLL]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
This is the third one that I've
done of this, so I can
teach you some TV
producing tips.
So whenever you do a complete
zinger like that, it's good to
kind of look at the camera and
just smile and nod a bit,
because you want to give people
time to recover from
their kind of gut-wrenching
laughter, or else they'll
start missing the important
facts and stuff.
So you're the big boss
of Left Logic, right?
REMY SHARP: That's right.
I run my own little
JavaScript-based development
agency thingamajiggy
in Brighton.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Cool.
So let's see what you Hove
got in store for us.
It kind of works, because
Brighton and Hove, right?
No, it doesn't work.
REMY SHARP: Separate place.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you built a
game for Google I/O, right?
REMY SHARP: Yeah, that's right.
If I--
well, we can demo
it now, right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
It's called-- what
is it called?
Face balls, ball faces?
REMY SHARP: Well, I'll show you
the game, and then I'll
give you some back story.
So--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Live
demos never fail.
REMY SHARP: The game's called
"Head Shots." You don't see
that bit where we did
it earlier, and the
whole machine crashed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh yeah.
If we seem a little bit
depressed, it's because we've
done a whole half an
hour recording.
It went really well.
And then Paul Kinlan, who's our
resident DJ today, just
kind of started crying.
A little tear ran down his
face, and he said, the
machine's crashed, dude.
Machine's crashed.
So this is our second
go at all of this.
But it's going to be
better, right?
REMY SHARP: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We should
positive about
it rather than depressed.
REMY SHARP: It's going
to be amazing.
So this amazing game is called
"Head Shots," and I'm going to
amazingly hit New Game.
And it's going to give
me a PIN number.
And that PIN number, Jake is
going to put into his phone.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I am.
It's a good feeling,
by the way.
REMY SHARP: Thanks.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This
is excellent.
I really like-- because I'm on
the PIN screen now, and it's
nice that when I go into the--
I don't know if this
is going to work.
When I go into the screen to
enter the PIN, it comes up,
and it's only got the numbers,
the digits on there, which
it's just putting them--
REMY SHARP: No, it's not.
It's a pattern.
So I think I might
not have mobile
connectivity, which is--
yes I do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We could put an
awkward transition in here
where we just put like a screen
and some hold music
until we're ready.
[HUMMING MUSIC]
REMY SHARP: Let's
try that again.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
we're back.
And we had a massive network
failure, right?
Because you're using a data
roaming SIM card.
You didn't realize you
were doing that.
And you've run out of credit,
which is probably costing you
quite a lot of money.
But we'll take you for a
beer to make up for it.
That'll be OK.
REMY SHARP: Beer equals data.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This
could be the moment
where Remy became bankrupt.
But we're going to soldier on.
What we're going to do is you've
got a pre-recorded
video of the game working.
We're going to look at that.
There was a great moment where
Paul was going to have the
whole camera running through us
fumbling and trying to make
the stream work and failing.
But Remy, you came up with
a good solution,
though, didn't you?
You just fired out a string of
obscene words, and that means
we can't put it out.
So I might use that
trick next time.
REMY SHARP: So yeah, that pretty
much guaranteed it
could never make it
to the public.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Exactly,
exactly.
So yeah, let's go through
the video.
REMY SHARP: Yeah, I'll walk you
through "Head Shots," the
pre-recorded version of
the interactive game.
So you're presented with
a welcome screen.
You tap on New Game
or Join Game.
So in this case, I'm going
to join a game.
I'm given a PIN number by the
other player, which actually
is going to be me.
So get prepared for your
minds to be blown.
And then when it prompts you, it
asks you if you want access
to the camera or not.
I say yes.
And you can see my face
being streamed
directly into the camera.
So here I get to throw a
ball at my own face.
And boom, in my face.
One down.
And then the other player kind
of flicks back, and you'll see
him throw the ball towards
me like that.
Awful shot, Remy, terrible.
And again.
Ah.
See now, I look like I hit
myself in the face with my
ball, but I didn't.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So it's actually
a live stream there?
REMY SHARP: It's
a live stream.
It's UDP data, peer to peer.
In this case, I was at home
using my own local network,
which means that the
connectivity should be superb,
because it's basically point
to point, almost.
There is one part that sits
on the server, the
discoverability of the game.
So knowing what PIN number, the
PIN number is what joins
us together in the
first place.
So there's a web--
oh, I hit myself again.
The server is running a
WebSockets server, which we
use to basically go up to and
say, what is the WebRTC
library, tell me what I need to
know to be able to connect
to this person.
It then sends down this data,
this magical data about where
the person's located, I guess.
And then it starts using things
like STUN, straight out
of "Star Wars," "Star Trek,"
in fact, TURN servers, ICE.
Because we like a bit of ICE
as well, some cool words.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So this is all
part of WebRTC, right?
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
And that then penetrates all the
firewalls and proxies and
gets us to hold hands and share
data and eventually be
able to get a peer
to peer point.
Hopefully.
It's still new technology,
that's the thing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's good.
I deliberately made a decision
not to learn any WebRTC
because it would make
this interview flow
a lot better, right?
It's not just because I'm
slightly incompetent, and
there's a big part of web
technology that I haven't even
looked at yet.
This is a deliberate interview
technique.
It's quite good.
REMY SHARP: Sound, sound.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Shall we have
a look at some of the code
that you're using to actually
make this connection happen?
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
So like you, I'm not that
well versed with WebRTC.
I should say as a caveat that
I'm a developer with the
approached that basically
bash away at
something until it fits.
And I watched my son putting
some blocks into a wall.
And basically, the way he was
getting the blocks through the
wall was the same
way as I code.
I basically just keep turning it
and turning it, and once it
works, it works,
and I move on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Even if it's not
the right shape, it fits.
REMY SHARP: Yeah, if you can
take a circle and turn it so
it looks like a square and push
it through a square hole,
then superb.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So we should
say the WebRTC stuff that
you're using there requires a
beta version of Chrome for
Android at the moment.
REMY SHARP: Yes, sorry.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But it's in
the full stable version of
Chrome desktop.
And it's also in the beta
version of Firefox as well.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But even though
it's in the beta,
you're having to turn on
some flags before that.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
So it might be worth
just looking at the
phone briefly, producer.
So down here, oh gosh,
somewhere.
So you probably have to do like
Find in Page, WebRTC.
And there we go.
So we've got the WebRTC flag
has been enabled manually.
And then you get the goodness
of the WebRTC technology.
Which I should, before I
show you some code, is
three sets of APIs.
So WebRTC is firstly,
getUserMedia, which is the API
that gets you the webcam and
basic video and audio.
And we've seen lots of demos
where people are mashing it up
with WebGL and so on.
The second part is the
DataChannel API, so
RTCDataChannel, which is like
WebSockets but gives you that
peer to peer connection.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you're not
just restricted to sending
video and audio.
It's normal data as well.
REMY SHARP: Yeah, yeah.
And with that, there's a flag
that allows you to set whether
it's reliable or not.
And reliable, true or
false, means switch
between UDP or TCP.
So you can use this for first
person shooter type games,
where it doesn't matter how many
bullets you fire, maybe.
I don't know.
I'm not the best games
developer, which is why I
wrote a game.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I don't
call it UDP.
I call it UPD.
REMY SHARP: Because we've
done this four times, I
now know that joke.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
I'm trying to recreate all the
spontaneous jokes we did in
the first record.
I don't think that one
was actually--
REMY SHARP: On the second.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: On the
second record.
Yeah, we're having a difficult
time trying to do--
REMY SHARP: Technology.
And the third part is
the DataChannel API.
So the DataChannel is what
allows me to stream video into
your device or stream video
out to multiple
devices peer to peer.
So it's those three technologies
put together that
gives you all of WebRTC.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So when we were
seeing the video there
and the game logic being sent,
that was just direct from
device to device.
It wasn't all going through
a central circle.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
So if you were making a game
that was player to player, you
don't need to have a huge server
that could control 100
games at once, because you can
sort of pass it off to
individuals.
REMY SHARP: Which does also
kind of bring its own
problems, like where does
the game logic belong?
How do you protect your game
from being hacked?
The way that I cleverly got
around that problem was to not
put any protection in there.
So if you want to hack
the game, you can do.
If I'm playing Jake and throwing
my balls at his face,
then I could just cheat.
And I could say, every single
one of them hit.
And I would win.
But obviously, I've cheated
you, and that would
make us both sad.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's for fun.
It's not a competitive--
REMY SHARP: Yeah, there's
no leader board or
anything like that.
So if I show you some of the
code, a lot of it's kind of--
there's events flying back and
forth inside of the game.
So when the game actually
starts--
let me scroll up just
a little bit.
I was actually on the right
line of code, pinchange.
I have this event that says
pinchange, which the server
will give me a new PIN
to start the game.
And when you enter a PIN into
your phone to start the "Head
Shots" game, it will trigger
this event called pinchange,
which tells the entire
application, right, go and
connect to the WebSocket
on the server
and send it the PIN.
And that's the room
I'm joining.
Because we need to be in
a room to be able to
communicate--
to discover each other
in the first place.
Once we've gotten into
that room, it then
fires a bunch of events.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So this dollar
on you've got there is just--
REMY SHARP: Yeah, so I
should say this is
not jQuery or Prototype.
This is I've written my own
little library that's min.js,
this tiny library just to
give me a few bits of--
a few shortcuts.
So on is an event listener.
And dollar on is just hitting
a dummy element.
So I've got this one, it's like
a simple pub/sub system.
And dollar is just
querySelectorAll with a smiley
face because it needs
a value, basically.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I completely
understand doing that.
Because I kind of worry about
the amount of finger skin that
I've lost to typing
addEventListener and
querySelectorAll when it--
yeah, on and dollar.
REMY SHARP: So I've got this
global event, pinchange, which
then tells the code to
go ahead and connect.
And this line above, rtc.on
connect, RTC is the webrtc.io
library's global object.
So there are a bunch of
different WebRTC libraries.
I settled on webrtc.io, mostly
because the demo was there in
the first place.
The demo is very hackable.
It meant that I had my prototype
up and running
really quickly.
It took me a couple of hours to
get my prototype working,
just based on that code.
There are a few bugs in it.
I should send pull requests
to fix the bugs.
There's some others, peer.js,
simplewebrtc.js.
I've got a feeling there's
another word in there
somewhere, but maybe not.
These are two libraries.
I think peer.js only did data,
and simplewebrtc only did
video and audio, but that
have changed by now.
This was a month ago or two
months ago I was working on
the project.
So webrtc.io is the one I
settled on just because I
needed to kind of hit the ground
running with WebRTC.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think this
is the real domain of
libraries in the future.
We used to use libraries just
to fix all the cross-browser
issues with the DOM.
But I think if you're dealing
with just modern browsers, the
need to do something like
that is less and less.
Like you have there just a tiny
micro-library to save
yourself some typing.
But we've got all of these new
web APIs, and a lot of them
are really low-level,
like WebGL
especially, Web Audio, WebRTC.
So I think this is where
libraries can really guide the
standards to show, these
are the common
actions people are doing.
And then that'll feed back into
the spec and hopefully
make it simpler.
REMY SHARP: So like in the
webrtc.io library, there's
code that looks for the Opus
codec or way of sending video,
which has to do with Firefox and
getting interoperability
between Firefox and Chrome.
I wouldn't know how
to do that.
And they're taking the message
and doing some kind of
rewriting magic stuff.
So magic.
That's what I'm looking for out
of my library is magic.
So when I get this connect
event, I then connect the
video, which is basically I
want to take your face and
stream it straight
into my phone.
And that connect video
looks like this.
Pretty straightforward.
I check that I can do
PeerConnection API.
I set up these options,
which says video
should be 320 by 180.
I'll come onto that
in a second.
And then WebRTC has this
helper, createStream.
And it fires this callback,
which I then trigger a custom
event that says the local
stream is ready.
And if I'm in debug mode, I
actually want to see it.
And the way that I've got my
game set up is that the local
feed is ready.
The remote feed is ready.
When they're both ready, we're
ready to play the game and
actually throw the balls.
Just going onto this bit, the
video mandatory maxWidth.
This is to say, basically, send
the video at 320 by 180.
And that's because my game only
has a very small kind of
icon for the video.
I had this kind of assumption
that, because it's with peer
to peer, that latency wouldn't
be a problem.
But realistically, if we're
playing a game, I could be
playing someone in the
US from the UK.
I'm still going over the wire,
still a lot of data.
This isn't a Skype
application.
It doesn't need all that data
to be going over the wire.
So I might as well make
it as small as I
need it in the game.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Would it make
sense to have a similar option
for frames per second?
Is it something that you
could bring down?
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
I think that there's stuff
to do with aspect ratio
that you can set.
There might be stuff to do
with frames per second.
Not all of it's implemented.
That's the thing.
And I, in fact, found that this
wasn't doing anything for
my code, because there's a bug
in webrtc.io where it's just
ignoring this value, which
could be fixed already.
But it's really new,
this technology.
So there's some parts that you
read about, like there's
mandatory and optional.
And I don't know if there's
frames per second.
There could well be.
It makes sense that you
would have that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
if the device--
I assume there's equivalents
for minimum
width and minimum height?
REMY SHARP: Yeah, I think so.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I guess that
would be somewhere where
if the device was incapable of
doing that, it would kind of
announce that.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
I don't know what happens if
it can't make it smaller.
Right.
So now, in this code, we've
made a connection to the
WebSockets server, discovered
the room, shared what room
we're joining.
We've got your face
into the game.
So this rtc.createStream is
behind the scenes basically
going to send it down the
PeerConnection API.
And this piece of code exposes
this init method.
And the init method inits
the connection.
And what that does is basically
listen for remote
streams, which is basically
me joining your game.
And when I join your game, it
attaches the stream, which is
the getUserMedia stream,
typically, to an element that
has an ID of remote.
And then I have this extra
check, which is where I've
found problems with not this
particular line of code.
But this is the line of code
that blocks the game from
actually running.
So when we were testing
earlier, we
were having some problems.
There's some kind of weird
network situation where the
data channel wouldn't open.
And if the data channel doesn't
open, the game's not
ready to play.
And only when the data channel
is open does it trigger the
remote is ready or
readyremote.
And when the readyremote
triggers, the game has a full
connection, both
video and data.
As in video and kind
of arbitrary data.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is this
the point where the
race condition happens?
REMY SHARP: Right.
OK, so the first version of this
code, I really wanted to
embrace the web in terms of
having URLs to access
different pages.
So I had a welcome page.
You hit Join, you go
to the join page.
And you have to put
in a PIN code.
And when you hit go, it would
take you to a waiting page,
and it would have this hanging
XHR request that would sit,
asking the server, is
the game ready?
And the game would say, no,
I'm in waiting stage.
I'm going to leave this
XHR connection open.
Now you would have your phone,
or I'd do it, whichever way
round I started.
And you would start a game, and
you would get a PIN code.
I've done this the wrong way
around, but you're still with
me anyways.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
yeah, I'm following.
REMY SHARP: You get a PIN code,
and it has the same
hanging XHR request
to the server.
And the game's one,
two, three.
And the server says, right,
we now have two
players in the game.
Change the state from
waiting to ready,
which closes the XHR.
The hanging XHR request comes
back to both of us.
It refreshes the page on
both of our devices.
And we're immediately then both
asked at the same time,
do you want to give access
to the audio and video?
Do you want to open up a data
stream to the other person?
And what I've found was it would
go, yep, they are, then
oh, it's broken.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you tried to
explain this to me before
we started recording.
And it wasn't quite
going on ahead.
So we decided, and I'm very
excited about the props, you
were going to try and
explain this.
REMY SHARP: I have an analogy.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So we have--
what do we have?
What is this?
REMY SHARP: So this
is my analogy for
trying to make a call.
So I'm trying to make
a call to you.
And I have my WebRTC
paper cup phone.
And the thing is, you're trying
to make a call to me,
and you have your WebRTC
paper cup phone.
So if I put my phone up to my
ear, and I try and make a call
to you, you want to
do the same thing.
So we're both trying to make
a call to each other.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I can
hear the ocean.
REMY SHARP: And I'm going to--
concentrate.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Sorry.
REMY SHARP: I'm going to try
and make a call to you.
So I'm going to give you this
side, and you're going to put
it up to your ear.
And you're going to give
me your phone.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, because
you need to make a call to me.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
And then I'm going to listen.
And see now, we're dangling.
We have dangly bits.
And this is why there's
like a flash of--
the moment I had the phone
still, there was a flash of
connectivity.
And the moment I kind of
let go, it just goes.
So that was with the help of
Paul Kinlan that I needed to
rewrite all my code into
a single-page app.
And by rewriting the code--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Are we done?
Sorry.
REMY SHARP: By rewriting the
code into a single-page app,
what happens is you start the
game, and you get your phone,
and you make your connection,
and you tell me what
the PIN number is.
And instead of me trying to
dial you, I already know
you're there.
And you give me the cup.
So then we can talk
to each other.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
not-- oh yes,
that's how phones work.
REMY SHARP: It should
be ear to ear.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I guess it's--
REMY SHARP: Streaming
consciousness.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think
if WebRTC is--
because the model we've built
here is you're either talking
or listening.
But WebRTC can do both, right?
So you would have--
REMY SHARP: I would have
a second one for data.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No,
other way around.
So my ear to your mouth.
REMY SHARP: This is why--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: There we go.
So that's WebRTC, right?
REMY SHARP: This is
the data-- yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is two
developers who don't know how
basic telephony works.
OK.
That helps.
I think that actually,
everyone would really
understand there, especially
with the cups.
REMY SHARP: The thing is, I
don't know if there's a bug in
my code, there's a bug in the
webrtc.io library, or if
there's just a bug generally
in the workflow of WebRTC.
And it was on Paul Kinlan's
advice to move to a
single-page app so that
you don't have that
race condition anymore.
And it solved the problem, and
I just wanted to move on and
work on the rest
of the problem.
But one day I'll revisit that
and try and work out where the
problem is.
And the thing is it's such new
technology that we need to be
making these mistakes.
And maybe that's the way
that you have to do it.
You need the single-page
app for persistence.
The example I was giving you
before, when we were talking
earlier, is if JSBin had a
video stream, if you were
teaching using JSBin, and you
had WebRTC in a video down in
the corner, if you wanted to
create a new bin, and you had
everyone kind of following
along, you couldn't refresh
the page, because when you
refresh, it will lose the
WebRTC connection.
You'll kill it.
So you'll need a single-page
app to say, right, new bin,
and it keeps the video, and I
can tell the people in my
class that here's the URL
via the chat window.
So someone should build
me that feature, too.
But yeah.
Anyway.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So the
other part of it was
the graphics, right?
You had things moving
in multiple layers.
How did you go about drawing
what we were
seeing on the screen?
REMY SHARP: So I started off
with just DOM nodes.
And the idea was
I'd just make--
I'd use a scale, translate
scale, transform scale.
I know how to code it.
I don't know how to say it.
And that would work, right?
So I thought I'd sit down with
Seb Lee-Delisle and just
borrow some advice off him.
And he kind of went, no.
You need to use three.js.
So I kind of put aside my lame
attempts at doing 3D with just
scaling a DOM, which
you can do.
It's more that I wouldn't
have managed to do it.
It would have looked crap.
And he pointed out that by using
three.js, we're able to
create a camera and a point of
view, and there's a real 3D
scene there in the
first place.
And the character that you're
throwing the ball at would
look the right size and
the right perspective.
And the ball as it
went through 3D
space would scale correctly.
Not your dodgy algorithm
to scale it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I had the same
problem because I haven't done
a lot of 3D programming.
So when it came to doing
something where something was
going to go away from the
camera, my first reaction was,
well, I've got the
scale value.
I can just move from
one to the other.
And you start to realize that
it doesn't quite move in the
same way, because it doesn't
have the perspective.
It's scaling linearly, whereas
when something moves further
away from you, it doesn't
scale linearly.
And I hacked it by using a
sine wave or something.
And it has that uncanny
valley of, it
doesn't look quite right.
So that's-- three.js
would solve that.
REMY SHARP: Yeah, that's what
he was pointing out, that by
using three.js to do this
properly, it will feel right
and will look right.
So I spent a couple of hours
with him and created this new
kind of scene with the floor,
and this object, it would
throw into the scene and
bounce off the floor.
Great.
Took that back to the office,
loaded it on the Android, had
a beautiful 60 frames per
second on the desktop.
Got a beautiful four frames
per second on the Android.
Pretty much wept into my lap.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What renderer
were you using
in three.js, though?
REMY SHARP: So that's just
the canvas renderer.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Normal
2D canvas, yeah?
REMY SHARP: The 2D
canvas, yeah.
And it's only post-project
I was like, oh, maybe I
should've had the
WebGL renderer.
Because I was allowed to choose
any technology I want.
But, you know, hindsight.
So I actually realized that the
problem that I was facing
was I was rendering a massive
scene, or a massive scene for
the device, at least.
And I found that by putting--
so I originally had both video
feeds going into the DOMs.
Both streams of video
were fueling these
two video DOM nodes.
And then I had this big canvas
that was being repainted all
the time, the entire background,
the whole thing.
So I changed the
code to being--
I created two three.js scenes.
One is the background, which
is the background, the 3D
floor, and the character who
is mostly stationary.
And then the second front
layer is the ball that
bounces, kind of comes down,
bounces, and then goes off and
reacts to the user flicking,
basically.
And instead of having two videos
in there, I got rid of
the second video, the video of
me, because I wouldn't need to
see myself when I'm
playing you.
And I just have your
face in there.
And that got the frames per
second back up to--
I think on Nexus 4, I was seeing
50 frames per second.
That isn't the end
of the project.
It kept on dipping up
and down, and I
would change something.
And suddenly it'd be 50
frames per second.
I'd change something else,
and suddenly it was
20 frames per second.
And I could have just been
mashing my keys, and that
would have kept changing,
basically.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So by having the
ball in its own layer, it
means you can move that
independently without having
to redraw this whole
background.
REMY SHARP: That layer
wasn't even moving.
It's just that there was less to
draw, less pixels to commit
to that canvas.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, and then
composite, it does the rest.
REMY SHARP: Yeah, exactly, so
you could see through, and
you'd see the background
of the character.
And I would fake the--
the ball would think it's hit
your face, but what I've
worked out is this is where
Jake's face should be and
bounce off of that, then cause
the background, the second
layer with the character to kind
of animate and fall down
and cry and spit blood
and eyeball falls out
and stuff like that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It reminds
me of my childhood.
I guess what you forfeit, then,
is you wouldn't be able
to make the ball go behind
the player, right?
Because you've got those
two separate layers.
But you don't have
that problem.
REMY SHARP: I did actually.
I do do that.
There is some code in there
that, again, with Seb's help--
I'm not a 3D programmer
in the first place.
And he was showing me, pointing
out the point where
the ball in the 3D scene would
have moved-- so if this is the
character here, and this
is our scene, the
ball would move forward.
And with the--
which one is that, x?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We'll
pretend it's x.
REMY SHARP: That's x.
And so when the x went behind
the character, I actually
flipped the canvases around.
Because I was only painting the
floor and the character on
there, the mountains are
actually completely
background, like a CSS
background on the actual body
of the element.
So it can go behind it.
There are moments where I think
the ball can bounce off
of something, and suddenly it's
coming forward, but it's
behind, or--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I've seen
you bounce it back.
REMY SHARP: There's something,
if you hit it between the
legs, there's something about
hitting that I've noticed.
If you hit the character between
the legs, the ball's
z-index doesn't work
out quite right.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hang on, what?
REMY SHARP: I don't
really know.
It's tricky to debug.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's
gloss over that.
Your game is just rife
with innuendo.
"Head Shots" was definitely the
best name you could have
picked for this.
Everything else is wrong.
REMY SHARP: There's these little
areas that basically
I've shaved corners off to try
and get a game that works and
people can see the technology
that is available natively in
the browser without plug-ins.
And if there's a few hitches
here and there, I'm
kind of OK with it.
It's the kind of thing I'd like
to go back and revisit.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What drove
the physics, then?
Because you've got the sort
of bouncy physics.
Was that just code you wrote, or
was that something that's--
you've got to use another
library, or
is that within three.js?
REMY SHARP: So I'd
like to show you
some of the code here.
In--
oh, where is it-- the game.js.
It, again, is just kind of
having Seb, but I think I knew
this already.
There's a lot of code
in the 3D stuff.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is stuff
you wrote, right?
REMY SHARP: This is
code I've written.
Seb did give me kind of large
chunks like the hit detection.
He gave me that, and the
projection, which I can
explain is mind-numbing.
So this stuff, he gave me,
when we sat down for that
two-hour session, he kind of
helped me get right as well.
He literally had to come around
to my office and sit
with me and say, Remy, Remy,
what are you doing?
Why are you doing this?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I can see
when it hits, the velocity is
obviously going to go in
the other direction.
REMY SHARP: Exactly.
So this, because we're doing
multiply recalls, we're
basically flipping the direction
every time it hits
that boundary.
So it's not that clever.
There's not much physics there
in the first place.
It just kind of slows it down.
Actually, there's no physics.
It's not proper physics,
at least.
There's just-- that's
not the code.
It's not pretty.
But it's just multiply by 0.7
each time on each bounce, so
it just eventually gets less
and less and less.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So how did you
go about building this?
What was your strategy?
Were you building it mostly in
the browser, or were you
building it alongside the
phone for the whole
development process?
REMY SHARP: It's
a bit of a mix.
Certainly, in fact,
that's pretty
much my workflow generally.
I try to do a bulk amount of
work directly in the browser.
So I've got Chrome
and Canary here.
So I do the bulk of my work
on the desktop browser.
And where I can, I'll be--
let's dock that bad boy.
Where I can, I'll use dev
tools to do all my
development.
And I've started using that in
JSBin as well, actually, just
using dev tools to
do the coding.
Let's make this nice and big.
I'm a big fan of right-click,
Save As, and then linking--
what's background.js?
That doesn't sound
like a real file.
Oh, confusing.
Hang on.
Bear with me.
So I don't know what that is.
No domain.
You guys build browsers.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hey,
it's your site.
REMY SHARP: That's true.
Oh, it's because no JavaScript
loaded on this page.
You have to actually
get into a game.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Ah, I see.
So the first intro page--
REMY SHARP: The first page
doesn't have any
JavaScript in there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
makes sense.
So part of the reason I guess
we're building it as just a
single-page app is because
you've got the full screen
support in there as well.
And once you have full screen,
if you were to change URL,
you'd lose that.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
So going back, using dev tools
here, there's a bug with the
PIN code coming down.
I will find the code
that handles that.
So let's just assume
it's start.js.
And I tend to just to be safe,
right-click, Save As, and then
put it to the right
directory, so JS.
And just overwrite it.
And I have live reload
turned on, don't I?
Have I?
Let's allow that.
And then I'll be just making
changes directly into this
code, so it's saving
directly to disk.
So I'm trying to debug what
PIN number is coming in.
So console log pin, save.
I think I've got live
reload going on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I like how the
dev tools are building up to
their own ID.
I think going back a few years
or certainly months, there was
kind of a push back on that.
It was like they didn't want
it to turn into a full ID.
But I think that's kind
of drifting now.
And it's nice to see some of
those features where you could
just start developing straight
into the dev tools.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
I'm a huge fan of--
sorry, I'm just going to save
it and live reload.
I'm a huge fan of coding
directly in dev tools.
Particularly with the animation
loops, where I've
got a loop that's rendering the
canvas each time, being
able to just change that inside
of the loop, seeing the
change instantly
is huge for me.
Being able to replay XHR.
Because I'm doing an XHR request
for the status of the
game, and if it kept coming back
and failing because there
was something wrong with the
server, all you need to do is
boot the server back
up and then
replay the network request.
And then I get to get that--
where is it?
Replay, replay--
it's somewhere, isn't it?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: See,
this is the thing.
This is the part I was hoping
you would show me, because
it's the feature I've
not actually used
in development myself.
I've always just, developing,
refresh the
page, do it all again.
So when you came to do stuff on
the device, did you use the
remote tools there?
I say that.
I saw you use it before.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's an
interview technique to pretend
that I don't actually know
what you're doing.
REMY SHARP: Like I said, the
first bulk is done on desktop.
And then the tweaking and the
refinement, I do between the
phone and desktop.
So do you want me to join me
show you it live on the phone?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, it'd
be cool to see that.
REMY SHARP: We might have to
pause during setup and--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, well, if
it's too much effort, we can
do something else.
Because it would be interesting
to see.
Because I know that we've
changed some stuff in Canary
that makes it easier to
do device discovery
as part of dev tools.
So we had this thing for so long
where you would have to
open up a command line.
We had a whole sort
of ADB thing.
The last time I was here,
I was doing that.
You have to type the thing that
everyone can remember.
I can't even remember it
off the top of my head.
I know it's in my
bash history.
But we're getting around a lot
of that stuff now with the
inspect menu in Canary.
How's that going, Remy?
I'm doing a very good
job of filling.
REMY SHARP: You're good.
I'm almost there, actually.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, brilliant.
REMY SHARP: So what I'm doing
here is basically finding the
IP address of this machine, and
I want to point my mobile
phone to the IP address
of the machine.
So 192--
I hope this works--
168.--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: All of the stuff
we've been doing so far
has been just successful
straightaway on the first try,
which is great.
REMY SHARP: Pretty much
out of the box.
It's like we can't do
anything wrong here.
So wow, look at that.
Right.
So I've got--
this is literally the setup
that I will use.
I'll point my phone to my
machine that I'm working on.
I'm working in Chrome, so I've
got Chrome Inspector.
What am I doing?
I'm not taking that route.
So sorry.
I use Chrome, all right.
I now have live reload
mixed into things.
And say I want to make a change
to this font size.
Let's see if this just works.
1.5 is way too small.
We want 7.5.
Oh yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's not
going to work, is it?
REMY SHARP: That should
have worked.
So it should have caused--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh wow.
REMY SHARP: Well, I don't want
to hit refresh on the phone
manually, because I've got
live reload in there.
It should be doing it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh
there we go.
REMY SHARP: So I'm making
changes in dev tools in Chrome
that it's saving.
Because it's saving the
style.css directly to disk,
it's causing the live reload
to trigger, which causes my
mobile phone to update.
Which means it can make those
fine grained adjustments.
Like maybe the height of the
page isn't quite right,
because there's too
much scroll.
I want to bring the About
links up a little bit.
I doubt I'll be able to
do this properly.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I suppose
you could connect dev tools
straight to the phone and
make these changes.
But the benefit you've got here
is that you're linked to
the files on the disk on your
laptop, and you're getting to
see the changes both
on desktop and on
mobile at the same time.
REMY SHARP: Yeah.
And I'm kind of hoping that--
oh, it's not affecting it now.
But I'm kind of hoping that
because I can go ahead and
inspect the page that we're
looking at on the phone
directly from Canary here--
I think I've got all kinds
of things running here.
So--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
the bit I like.
Because that's the bit, we don't
have to use ADB anymore
to do that weird incantation
just to connect to the device.
REMY SHARP: This, for me, is
perfect, because I've got the
newest version of dev tools.
I've got all the
network stacks.
Refresh there.
Let me try that again.
Yeah, so I've got the
full network stack.
Here, if I had XHR requests, I
could replay them actually on
the device.
My full debugger, break
points and so on.
The one bit that I'm missing,
and since I'm here at Google--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hi, welcome
to Google Developers Live.
This is mobile web Thur--
Hi, welcome to Google
Developers Live.
This is mobile web Thursday.
But actually, we're not live.
We're pre-recording this.
And I guess it's not really
Google Developers either,
because you're not
one of the gang.
So I guess it's just developers,
not live, in the
Google studios.
It's not GDL, it's DNLIAGS.
Din-a-lags.
DNLIAGS.
That's cool.
That sounds a bit like dinner
ladies, I don't know.
We could go with that.
REMY SHARP: Din ladies.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Anyway, in the studio today,
we've got Remy Sharp, from off
of the internet, from
down in Brighton.
And I certainly hope he's going
to brighten the studio.
REMY SHARP: [DRUM ROLL].
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
This is the third one that I've
done of this, so I can
kind of teach you some
TV producing tips.
So whenever you do a complete
zinger like that, it's good to
kind of look at the camera and
just smile and nod a bit.
Because you want to give people
time to recover from
their kind of gut-wrenching--